Visualisierung der Ergebnisse des Stromnetzmodells
Was bedeutet das denn eigentlich?
Fangen wir am besten mit der Ausgangssituation an.
Siemens entwickelt ein Programm, welches die
Fehler im Stromnetzmodell berechnet und aktuell
in Log Files speichert.
Diese Log Files sind äußerst unübersichtlich
und es kann lange dauern, bis ein Ingenieur
von Siemens den Ursprung des Fehlers gefunden hat.
Genau hier wird unsere Applikation relevant.
Wir haben ein System entwickelt, welches die
Fehlerdaten von Siemens über das Apache Kafka
System - das ist ein Message Bus - an das
Backend übergibt und dort persistiert.
Das Backend ist mittels Java Spring Framework
und PostgreSQL Datenbank implementiert.
Über eine GraphQL Schnittstelle kann das
Angular Frontend die Daten visualisieren.
Kommen wir nun zu den Besonderheiten unserer Applikation.
Aufgrund des Message Busses ist unsere Applikation
optimal von dem Service von Siemens entkoppelt.
Dies ermöglicht eine einfache Integration
in die Production bei Siemens.
Das Frontend bietet ideale Möglichkeiten,
um die Daten zu analysieren.
Wie Sie hier sehen können, verfügt es über
ein Dashboard, welches die vier Eigenschaften,
Klasse, Kategorie, Schweregrad und Spannungslevel, darstellt.
Das Herzstück der Applikation ist jedoch
die Tabelle, welcher jegliche Art von Such-
und Filtermöglichkeiten implementiert.
Man kann die Daten nicht nur Sortieren, sondern
eben auch nach gewissen Begriffen, und den
vier vorhin genannten Eigenschaften filtern.
Ein wichtiger Bestandteil ist auch der Button
zum Zurücksetzen aller Filter.
Kommen wir nun zum Graph.
Dieser zeigt einen Teil des Stromnetzwerkes an.
Hierbei ist das Objekt mit dem aktuellen Fehler
in blau dargestellt, sodass die Ingenieure von Siemens
die nähere Umgebung des Fehlers analysieren können.
Dadurch ist das Ausfindigmachen des Ursprungs
sehr effizient, sodass das Netzmodell schnellstmöglich
wieder funktionieren kann.
Das ist auch schon wieder das Ende unseres kurzen Videos.
Wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen.